as more nevadans get the covid vaccine
there's talk about potentially needing a
third dose
thank you for joining us i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez pfizer's
ceo
saying today a third booster shot will
likely be needed within a year of
getting the second dose
oracle mana joining us now live tonight
to explain orco
well denise and brian according to the
state's covet 19 dashboard
around 21 percent of nevadans are fully
vaccinated
but it's still unclear how long that
protection will last
experts say we can't expect booster
shots and local businesses we spoke to
say
if that's the case they encourage
everyone to get them
[Music]
motown music fills the room at notoriety
the live performance venue in downtown
las vegas seeing more customers in
recent weeks
we're putting bodies in the in the seats
so it's been good
notoriety ceo ken henderson tells me
increased capacities have been helpful
but he says the best way to boost
business is if everyone
gets the covet 19 vaccine the more
people that get vaccinated the more
people are confident coming out and the
more people are buying tickets and
and coming out and enjoying live
entertainment nevada's vaccine rollout
is making progress but this could be
just the beginning pfizer ceo saying a
booster will likely be needed within one
year of getting the second shot
it's not surprising dr mark j khan says
this could be similar to the flu shot
which is given annually
as of now both pfizer and moderna have
said their coven 19 vaccines
are effective for at least six months
it's just not clear how long after that
it's going to
persist i would expect that we're going
to get
booster vaccines for covid
for the next several years to come local
wellness retreat host alicia younis says
if that happens she hopes people make
the right decision
so businesses like hers can fully reopen
many of us
want to continue to do what we're doing
feels the same way the key is to to get
back to our normal life
again a potential third dose of the
copin 19 vaccine is still not official
researchers are continuing to look into
it to see if it'll be necessary
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now